[Music]
well under the situation I wash my face
I think Martin personally don't see me
so Martin Lawrence was just something
comedic genius he still is a comedic
genius but in his problem I mean to be
able to watch him every week and be
dynamic on this show I love the show
relationships
[Music]
so we're about to watch mine I just
figured I'd give you out of my house
first of all BAM hair sanitizer this is
baby Jameer why'd you put me in the
sailor suit welcome to my room
hey mom she keeps the chair in here
because she lets me know all right this
is only a pit stop right this is my
bedspread this I could really let you
know that uh so this is the first
episode of Martin what's in the first
episodes yeah they were living insane
mom
[Applause]
that's love I don't like how they got
there outside clothes on in the bed
though with the Emmy
hmm where was the Emmy I would say was
what in that one episode was interesting
a lot of things played out okay the
mother father issues playing out mother
had a mustache you know you can say but
mom and then when he told mother shut up
I was like whoa you know okay that was
the line line hey get him up you there
you go my hey what move is that I don't
know so it is day two of Martin marathon
my mother my mother's going a little
crazy - singing Negro spirituals what's
the song you were singing all right all
right we don't need hit hit you make it
be nervous I'm very happy that Martin is
bringing us together in this nominee so
I'm excited oh okay okay okay this is
why you need to get away so your mother
wants a Negro spirituals not all mothers
okay
season two is actually my favorite
season of mourning yeah not a lot of
memorable episodes that people consider
classic
[Laughter]
classic moment classic moment this
episode is called Hollywood swinging
part one listen it's a um it's a
two-parter okay what the name continues
to come up varnel hill
it's just anonymous with this show cuz
he he has such a big impact on the show
from these two episodes Claudine GTT
what does GTD extend what do you think
GTD stands for I was thinking it was the
name of Corinne is the name of a movie
what does G T D stand for
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey it's day 3 - Martin marathon still
under quarantine nothing has changed I
am Martin Dallas but I am Martin out so
gonna grab some fine because what are
things there to do are you ready mommy
wrapping this up you ready to make an
Italian mom you got ketchup what's
happening chief
what's happening James what's up you
know my sales slogan you wanted I got if
I ain't got I'm gonna get it so get it
while the getting's good
so Tracy Morgan played a character
called hustle man in the spots that he
had or Martin he made it work very brief
but always the Steen still up that's
right you give me a Tracy Morgan
impression I don't know what that what's
happening cheap got short like that
you've got something like that one short
like Tracy look don't make that cake
silligans Island wanted it look the
physical aspect of physical comedy yes
yes turned all the way up in season
three yes yeah yeah yeah I'm just
letting you know
[Music]
so be a watch Martin just finished it
how you feel
I've right after give me your your point
I really loved it I loved the first
couple of seasons at the end you can see
you know like the demise and the
creativity and you know the energy with
the cast yeah dramatically the first
couple of seasons it was like really
hype and special and then it was sad I
almost felt like I was losing the part
of the fan and it felt bad it really
does alright so three days three days we
watched Martin and we bonded as you feel
about the overall show going into it and
now that you have watched it or most of
it a lot I've learned a lot about that
show and I'm great you know more about
you know how you you're processing and
so genius-level yeah yeah did it change
your mind about anything but like any
preconceived notions that you might have
had about Barton going into it when I
watched it way back when when I quote
glimpses of the show even though I give
you members something like the rhythm I
can respond back and you started
watching but I just thought it was just
a normal life you know tomfoolery kind
of Oh
for example we kind of sitcom and then
watching it at this point in time and
now you know in terms of miles and hours
great base and appreciation for the art
and hit head on it
comedic artists and genius it was like
brilliance now I'm going to put your
knowledge to the test okay and ask you
some questions about Martin okay
Martin's first job was at a radio
station
what were the letters of the radio
station wzu P okay so we saw it Gina
throughout this show rolling bridge
gradually grow to become a senior vice
president over said job and where does
she work
sang it in the background what was the
name of one talk show word on the street
Oh word I swear I'm not sure that's all
right I give you a partial credit you
want partial best name for characters
that Martin played outside of Martin
Payne Roscoe right Sheneneh and I know I
will give it to you you know you guys
mom paying like Sheneneh Roscoe Otis is
a security guard is the last question at
the very end of the series
Mario write something on the wall as he
maybe you know next time we'll watch one
of your shows that you will movies what
[Music]